the owasp API security top 10 is a
standard reference guide highlighting
the most critical web API
vulnerabilities to help developers and
organizations understand and mitigate
potential security threats in this
course you will learn about each
security risk and learn techniques to
fortify your apis against potential
threats Corey ball developed this course
he is a cyber security consultant and a
leading expert in API security so he's
the perfect person to teach you how to
secure your apis
hello free code Camp community and
welcome to appisec University in this
course on oauth's API security top 10
and beyond my name is Dan barahona I'm
the co-founder of appisec University and
for the next 90 minutes you'll learn all
about the owasp API security top 10
updated in 2023 and will even add a few
extra bonus topics that are really
important to know about your instructor
for the course is my good friend Corey
ball author of The hacking apis book and
well recognized expert in the field of
API security
I invite you to check out all our free
courses over on appisec University
including a Hands-On course on API pen
testing an introductory course on API
security fundamentals this course here
on the oauth API top 10 as well as a PCI
compliance course and API documentation
course and many more to come
all the courses on our site include
quizzes to assess your knowledge and if
you complete everything and pass the
final quiz we'll issue you a certificate
and badge to recognize your
accomplishment which you can also
display on your LinkedIn profile thanks
again for watching and I hope you enjoy
the course
[Music]
welcome to oauth API security top 10 and
Beyond in this course we will dive into
the latest updates to the oasp API
security top 10 and discuss other
significant security considerations
beyond the top 10. the first edition of
the API security top 10 was released in
2019 and now oauth has officially
released the 2023 version as apis are a
critical component of the modern Digital
World this list is of utmost importance
this course highlights the most common
API security vulnerabilities and is
meant to help educate the community of
Builders Breakers and Defenders
the course will help you identify and
analyze the most common weaknesses that
plague modern web application
programming interfaces or APS
by the end of this course you should
have an understanding of the variety of
vulnerabilities associated with apis the
attack vectors involved and the
technical impact and exploited
vulnerability could have
so who is this course for this course is
great for anyone involved in the API
economy it is meant to help improve the
skills and knowledge of bug bounty
hunters developers penetration testers
organizational leadership and anyone
else interested in learning about API
security
before taking this course you should be
familiar with API security fundamentals
if you would like to learn more about
this check out our API security
fundamentals course
so how does this course work read watch
and or listen to the content provided in
the course modules it is highly
recommended that you take notes explore
the recommended resources follow along
with the course materials and complete
the quizzes at the end of every module
the content presented in the video
should closely align with the written
content the videos offer Visual and
audible alternatives to consuming the
content of this course
quizzes during the course quizzes will
be used to validate your knowledge
quizzes are knowledge-based multiple
choice tests based on the content
discussed within the given module the
oasp API security top 10 and Beyond
course is meant to be a challenging
course that sets a high bar to pass any
quiz or assessment you must answer 100
of the questions correctly completing
all quizzes will result in obtaining a
certificate of completion this course is
entirely free and you can earn the
certificate of completion by passing all
course modules and passing all the
quizzes those who would like to certify
their knowledge can take the course exam
the exam is a knowledge-based assessment
of your ability to analyze apis and find
vulnerabilities students who pass the
exam will earn the certified API
security analyst certification or casa
formatting please note that all content
in italics under sections designated OAS
is sourced directly from the oasp API
security top 10 2023 this content is
attributed to the OS API security
project team and oasp API security
project contributors all other sources
will be directly referred to no changes
were made to the content
hey everyone quick introduction my name
is Corey ball I'm the author of hacking
apis technical editor of black hat
graphql and contributor to the OS API
security top 10 2023
I'm also the chief hacking officer for
appisec University and a senior manager
of penetration testing over at Moss
Adams I have over 13 years of experience
working in it and cyber security across
several Industries in addition to a
bachelor's degree in English and
philosophy from Sac State I also hold
several certs including the oscp ccso
cisp and several others I hope you enjoy
this course
the objective of this course is to help
students become API Security
Professionals and be able to identify
and reduce API related security risks
oasp API security top 10 and Beyond is
meant to help improve the skills of bug
bounty hunters developers penetration
testers organizational leadership and
anyone else interested in learning about
API security
course objectives include the
introduction to oasp the API security
project and the changes from the 2019 to
the 2023 version
it should help prepare students to pass
the certified API security analyst or
Casa exam
develop a strong foundation in the
following API security risks broken
object level authorization broken
authentication broken object property
level authorization unrestricted
resource consumption broken function
level authorization unrestricted access
to sensitive business flows server-side
request forgery security
misconfiguration improper Inventory
management unsafe consumption of apis in
addition to that it's to help secure the
apis of the internet and prevent API
related data breaches
finally this course is meant to help
prepare students with additional
resources for continued learning and
growth in API security
foreign
the open web application security
project or oasp is a non-profit
Foundation that was created to help
improve application security the OS
Foundation launched on December 1st 2001
and is most well known for its top 10
lists open source tools and other
security projects the oauth API security
top 10 is a list of the most critical
security risks for application
programming interfaces the founders of
the project include irres Yellen and
inonsketti the OS API security top 10
was originally released in December 2019
and was driven by several key factors
the first was the rapid rise of apis
apis power the flow of the world's most
valuable resource which is data a
business no longer needs to specialize
in all aspects of creating software
instead they can use the features of
software shared by other companies and
organizations historically the issue
with doing this was the disconnected
major of different programming languages
web application programming interface
cases allowed for a common method to
consume or provide data across the
internet
since the widespread adoption of web
apis organizations have been enabled to
leverage the functionality of other
applications instead of having to
develop custom software for Maps GPS
Payment Processing authentication
communication and much more developers
can leverage apis to use the
functionality of other applications that
specialize in that given area apis are a
major business enabler which explains
the global rapid adoption
second a major Gap in security so the
next factor that compounded the effects
of the other two is the fact that the
tools and techniques of the past were
not effective at detecting API related
vulnerabilities the tools and techniques
that were used for Enterprise
vulnerability Management Programs web
application scanners and traditional
network security monitoring tools were
not designed to handle the unique
challenges posed by apis as a result
many organizations were not adequately
prepared to defend against API attacks
leaving them vulnerable to data breaches
third a new leading attack Vector often
when it comes to the rapid adoption of
new technologies security is in the
afterthought apis are no different the
rapid adoption of apis led to a new
attack Vector that exposes data
application functionality
public internet-facing apis often
bypassed all the security measures that
had grown with businesses over the past
decades an attacker no longer needs to
go through the classic miter cyber kill
Chain by bypassing the firewall gaining
entry to the network pivoting around to
A system that contains data and then
finding a way to exfiltrate that data
instead an attacker can use an insecure
API and have direct access to that
sensitive data in response to the
massive adoption of apis the security
gaps introduced by API providers and the
new wave of API related security
incidents the oasp API security project
published its top 10 lists the API
focused top 10 list provides a
comprehensive set of guidelines best
practices and tools to help
organizations secure their apis and
protect against API related threats
the OS API security project has become a
widely recognized and respected resource
for Security Professionals and has
helped raise awareness of the importance
of API security
how is the top 10 compiled as described
by Paula Silva or ask BPI security
project leader the 2023 oasp API
security top 10 list is put together by
the project team based on internal
research based on publicly available
data bug Bounty platforms and news since
the project did not receive any data
during the call for data during the
two-month window in late 2022 the top 10
list was compiled based on the project
team's research this was not something
new or different for the project as this
is as Silva stated what was done in 2019
without data sets received from the
community the OAS project team had to
compile data based on public disclosures
from bug Bounty platforms and API
security incidents that made it into the
news although this data set isn't as
ideal as data compiled directly from
testing hundreds of thousands of
endpoints across the internet it does
represent a sample of real world API
weaknesses some potential issues with
applying this data include bug Bounty
program incentivizes certain types of
findings over others bug Bounty programs
attract participants that represent a
small sample of the apis that are
actually out in the wild newsworthy
incidents often leave security
researchers without specific technical
details obviously newsworthy incidents
do not include all of the breaches and
security incidents that are not reported
or publicized that being the case there
are lessons to be learned and risks to
be aware of based on bug Bounty
write-ups and publicized security
incidents if you are interested learning
more about the sources below is a list
of common websites to dive deeper into
bug Bounty research
in addition to these attached to this
module is a Json extract from
pentesterland that contains all
documented API write-ups pen testerland
write-up compilation hacker one activity
awesome bug Bounty write-ups all the
links are in the content below also in
the course content is a list of some of
the most newsworthy API incidents in the
last five years including data breaches
and leaks from the USPS optis T-Mobile
and Toyota
the oasp API security top 10 list
contains common groups of the most
critical security risks to be on the
lookout for based on these sources
the oasp API security risks are
associated with references to external
sources these sources include cwes or
common weakness enumeration
other OS projects and the National
Institute of Standards and technology or
nist guidance
most of the references involve cwes cwes
are a list of common software and
Hardware vulnerabilities developed by
the community and hosted by miter each
gwe is identified by a unique identifier
or cweid
this identifier can be used to refer
back to a specific vulnerability
check out the Full Table of external
sources in the course material below
understanding the external sources and
how they're associated with a given
oaspa API security top 10 risk will help
provide you with additional Insight
throughout the course external sources
will be provided for the oasp API
security top 10 risks
these resources will be provided to you
to help you dive in as deep as you'd
like into the topic of API security
we will dive deeper into these in later
modules in the next section we'll go
over the updates to the top 10 list from
2019 to 2023.
since the release of the OS API security
top 10 in 2019 API usage has grown API
related data breaches have continued and
new API technologies have emerged all
this has played a role in the need for
an updated version of the API security
Project's top 10 list since the 2019 top
10 several events have demonstrated the
importance of keeping the list updated
and relevant API attacks are
consistently on their eyes Akamai
reported seeing nearly 114 million API
attacks in a single day in 2021 the
global API market value is valued at 2.2
billion dollars in 2021 and was
predicted to reach 41.5 by 2031 that's a
20 times growth rate in 10 years in 2022
Postman had over 46 million Postman
Collections and GitHub had 3 million API
related repos
apis continue to be rapidly adopted and
the financial Stakes continue to climb
the oasp API security project updated
the top 10 list to address some of the
changes in the attack trends of emerged
since the previous version
osppi security project leader stated
that the OAS API top 10 2023 version is
different from the 2019 version We
aspire to follow the security trends
that are relevant to apis and have been
developed in recent years
if you try to hack or protect an API
that was developed five years ago it
would make more sense to refer to the
2019 list
at a high level when you compare the top
10 from 2019 to 2023 you see that two
previous risks were removed from the
list three remained exactly the same
four were updated and five of the 2023
are new
the two items that were removed included
injection and insufficient login
monitoring these two risks were not
completely mitigated and resolved but
the importance of new emerging risks
pushed them beyond the top ten logging
and monitoring is a classic OAS top 10
risk but it is not an item that is
represented in breaches or disclosed bug
values injection attacks are still
around and many web apis are still
susceptible but the adoption of web
application firewalls and implementation
of other mitigation techniques has
reduced the occurrence of notable API
injection
there are three categories that remained
on the list broken object level
authorization or Bola broken function
level authorization or bathla and
security misconfiguration
Bola and bathla are still among the most
common API risks account for many of the
breaches in bug Bounty disclosures apis
continue to have severe issues when it
comes to authorization risk
the security misconfiguration category
contains a wide range of possible
misconfigurations that can plague apis
in other words this category is unlikely
to leave the top 10 because it is a
catch-all for many API vulnerabilities
four categories were renamed the
renaming of these categories help
simplify the risk categories and bring
additional Focus to the issue at hand
broken user authentication has now
become broken authentication this
simplification has done away with user
and now brings additional attention to
the API authentication as a whole
process
improper assets management has become
improper Inventory management this
change was likely made to better align
with industry terminology and to cover a
wider range of resources the term assets
might only refer to tangible items
valued by an organization while the term
inventory could refer to a wider set of
resources
there were a total of five categories
that were added to the API security top
10 2023 that were not on the 2019
version
server-side request forgery and unsafe
consumption of apis are completely new
and did not have previous representation
on the 2019 osbpi security top 10 list
server-side request forgery was
represented on the 2021 OAS top 10 list
and was added to that list based on
survey results rather than by incident
occurrence the remaining new risk
categories included broken object
property level authorization or Poplar
unrestricted resource consumption and
unrestricted access to sensitive
business flows each containing elements
from the 2019 list
for example is a combination of
excessive data exposure and mass
assignment and we will dive deeper into
each of these later in the course paired
with each oasp API security risk
category are risk ratings the risk
ratings were based on the oauth's risk
rating methodology the project now
refers to the osbury's gradings
framework in the written course content
there is a table demonstrating the risk
ratings used for the OAS API security
project from the OAS API security top 10
2019 PDF any of these factors could
significantly affect the overall
likelihood of an attacker finding and
exploiting a particular vulnerability
this rating does not take into account
the actual impact on a specific business
the risk score must be determined by the
given organization as the project team
states the purpose of the OAS API
security top 10 is not to do this risk
analysis for you in other words the
purpose of the oasp API security top 10
was not to perform a specific risk
analysis for a given organization but to
provide a guideline for organizations to
consider risk factors
in the course content you can see a
table containing the changes to the 2019
and 2023 risk ratings
the classic equation for risk is
likelihood multiplied by impact with
each risk score the oasp API security
project team has left the impact as a
relative value to be determined by the
business in addition a project team
includes a note along with these scores
that the likelihood of these scores is
not taken into account
what we are left with are values that
represent overall exploitability
including complexity exploitability
weakness prevalence weakness
detectability and Technical impact note
that the overall score does not equate
to a risk score because significant
factors such as business impact and
likelihood are not accounted for
API 1 2023 broken object level
authorization or Bola is one of the most
prevalent and severe vulnerabilities or
apis all vulnerabilities occur when an
API provider does not have sufficient
controls in place to enforce
authorization in other words API users
should only have access to sensitive
resources that belong to them when Bola
is present an attacker will be able to
access the sensitive data of other users
the OAS attack Vector description States
attackers can exploit API endpoints that
are vulnerable to a broken object level
authorization by manipulating the ID of
an object that is sent within the
request object IDs can be anything from
sequential integers uuids or generic
strings regardless of the data type they
are easy to identify in the request
Target either through the path or a
query string parameter request headers
or even as a part of the request payload
the of security weakness description
States this has been the most common and
impactful attack on apis authorization
and access control mechanisms in modern
web applications are complex and
widespread even if the application
implements a proper infrastructure for
authorization checks developers might
forget to use these checks before
accessing a sensitive object Access
Control detection is not typically
amenable to automated static or dynamic
testing
OS impact description States
unauthorized access can result in data
disclosure to unauthorized parties data
loss or data manipulation unauthorized
access to objects can also lead to full
account takeover
if an API endcoin has insufficient
access controls it will not perform
checks to ensure users can only access
their own resources when these controls
are missing user a will be able to
obtain user B's resources via API
requests
apis use some sort of value like names
or numbers to identify various objects
when an attacker discovers an api's
resource ID they will attempt to obtain
the resources when unauthenticated or
authenticated as a different user for
instance imagine that an authenticated
user Bruce sends a get request to
herohospital.com API V3 users
ID equals 2727 and receives a Json
response back with his data this poses
no problem Bruce should be able to
access Bruce's own information however
if Bruce is able to access another
user's information then a bowl of
vulnerability would be present this
weakness can be tested by using other
resource IDs in place of 2727
say Bruce is able to obtain information
about another user by sending a request
to
API V3 users ID equals 2728 and receives
a response about Harvey Dent and his
dissociated identity disorder then there
would be a problem assuming that Bruce
is still using his authorization to
access this data this would be a clear
indication that the API is vulnerable to
Bola
Bola isn't always as simple as this
example because there's flexibility in
how resources are provisioned and
requested from one API to the next the
written course content contains several
examples of how API resources may be
requested and attacked in these examples
tests can be performed by replacing the
bolded resource IDs with other numbers
or words of course in post requests the
resource could also be requested in the
post body
if user a can successfully access the
information of any other user then there
is a vulnerability present bowl of
vulnerabilities are the most common API
vulnerabilities and are easily
exploitable and require a low amount of
technical skills in order to discover
these Bola can present itself in many
forms depending on how resources are
organized as you can see in the written
course content resources can be
organized by a user by group or by a
combination of both in all these
instances only those with the proper
permission should be allowed to retrieve
their resources
the oasp preventative measures state in
order to improve API security it is
important to implement robust
authorization controls these controls
should consider user policies and
role-based access control hierarchies
the primary focus should be to ensure
that authenticated users only have
access to resources they are authorized
to have access to using less predictable
resource IDs can increase the challenge
of a user or attacker guessing the
resource ID of other users developers
should perform tests that specifically
test for authorization controls
Implement a proper authorization
mechanism that relies on the user
policies and higher
use the authorization mechanism to check
if the logged in user has access to
perform the requested action on the
record in every function that uses an
input from the client to access the
record in the database prefer the use of
random and unpredictable values such as
goods for records IDs write tests to
evaluate the vulnerability of the
authorization mechanism do not deploy
changes that make the tests fail check
out the written course content for
additional resources about Bola
API 2 2023 broken authentication refers
to any weakness within the API
authentication process all apis that
contain sensitive information should
have some mechanism to authenticate
users authentication is the process that
is used to verify the identity of an API
user whether that is a person device or
system
in other words authentication is the
process of verifying that an entity is
who that entity claims to be this
verification process is normally done
with the use of a username and password
combination token and or multi-factor
Authentication
authentication related vulnerabilities
typically occur when an API provider
either doesn't Implement a strong
authentication mechanism or implements
an authentication process incorrectly
the oasp attack Vector description for
this states that the authentication
mechanism is easy target for attackers
since it's exposed to everyone although
more advanced technical skills may be
required to exploit some authentication
issues exploitation tools are generally
available
the Olaf's security weakness description
States software and security Engineers
misconceptions regarding authentication
boundaries and inherent implementation
complexity make authentication issues
prevalent
methodologies of a detecting broken
authentication are available and easy to
create
the OS impacts description States
attackers can gain complete control of
other users accounts in the system read
their personal data and perform
sensitive actions on their behalf
systems are unlikely to be able to
distinguish attackers actions from
legitimate user ones
broken authentication continues to be a
significant security issue due to poor
password policies weak authentication
mechanisms and misconfigurations
API authentication is a complex process
that is commonly found with most apis
and is necessarily exposed
the impact of broken authentication can
lead to an attacker taking control of
user accounts compromising personal data
and conducting sensitive actions like
editing someone else's Healthcare data
the authentication process is often one
of the first lines of defense for apis
and when this mechanism is vulnerable it
can lead to a data breach
a weak password policy does not
sufficiently protect user accounts by
enforcing strong password creation and
management
this allows users to create simple
passwords allows Brute Force attempts
against user accounts and allows users
to change their password without asking
for password confirmation
also allowing users to change their
email without asking for password
confirmation weak password policies also
disclose tokens or passwords in the URL
it has a lack of authentication for
sensitive requests and in regards to
graphql queries weak password policies
would allow for many authentication
attempts within a single request
credential stuffing is a type of attack
against the authentication where a large
number of username and password
combinations are attempted credentials
used in these types of attacks are
typically collected from data breaches
this sort of attack allows users to
Brute Force many different username and
password combinations without
restrictions
predictable tokens refers to any token
obtained through a wheat token
generation authentication process weak
tokens can easily be guessed deduced or
calculated by an attacker
this would be an issue if an API is
using incremental or guessable tokens
for IDs
jwts are commonly used for API
authentication and authorization
processes JWT stands for Json web tote
jwts provide developers with the
flexibility to customize which algorithm
is used for signing the token the key
and secret that is used and the
information used in the payload this
customization allows for plenty of room
for security misconfigurations to occur
these include API providers that accept
unsigned JWT tokens API providers that
do not check WT expirations API
providers that disclose sensitive
information within the encoded JWT
payload and if the JWT is signed with a
weak key
API authentication can be a complex
system that includes several processes
with a lot of room for failure couple
decades ago security expert Bruce
schneier said the future of digital
systems is complexity and complexity is
the worst enemy of security as we know
from the six constraints of rest apis
restful apis are designed to be
stateless to be stateless the API
providers shouldn't need to remember the
consumer from one request to another
for this constraint to work apis often
require users to undergo a registration
process to obtain a unique token the
token that is generated is then used in
subsequent requests for authentication
and authorization
as a consequence the registration
process used to obtain an API token the
token handling and the system that
generates the token could all have their
own set of weaknesses if the token
generation process doesn't rely on a
high level of Randomness or entropy
there's a chance that an attacker will
be able to create their own token or
hijack another user's token
the other authentication processes that
could have their own set of
vulnerabilities include aspects of the
registration system like password reset
and multi-factor authentication features
for example imagine a password reset
feature requiring you to provide an
email address and a six-digit code to
reset your password
while the API allowed you to make as
many requests as you wanted you'd only
have to make 1 million requests in order
to guess the code and reset any user's
password a four digit code would require
only ten thousand requests
as it states in the OAS preventative
measures make sure you know all the
possible flows to authenticate to the
API
ask your engineers What flows you missed
read about your authentication
mechanisms make sure you understand what
and how they are used oauth is not
authentication and neither are API keys
don't reinvent the wheel in
authentication token generation or
password storage use the standards
credential recovery and forgot password
endpoints should be treated as log and
endpoints in terms of Brute Force rate
limiting and lockout protections require
re-authentication for sensitive
operations including changing the
account on your email address and
multi-factor phone number
use the oasp API authentication cheat
sheet you can find that in the written
content
where possible Implement multi-factor
Authentication
Implement anti-brute Force mechanisms to
mitigate credential stuffing dictionary
attacks and Brute Force attacks on your
authentication endpoints this mechanism
should be stricter than the regular rate
limiting mechanisms on your apis
Implement account lockout capture
mechanisms to prevent Brute Force
attacks against specific users Implement
weak password checks API Keys should not
be used for authentication they should
only be used for API client
Authentication
check out the written course content for
additional resources about broken
Authentication
API 3 2023 broken object property level
authorization or poplab is a combination
of two items from the 2019 OSP API
security top 10. excessive data exposure
and mass Society
excessive data exposure takes place when
an API provider responds to your request
with an entire data object usually an
API provider will filter out the data
object down to what is being requested
when the data object is shared without
being filtered there is an increased
risk of exposing sensitive information
mess assignment is a weakness that
allows for user input to alter sensitive
object properties if for example an API
uses a special property to create admin
accounts only authorized users should be
able to make requests that successfully
alter those administrative properties if
there are no restrictions in place then
an attacker would be able to elevate
their Privileges and perform
administrative action by altering those
properties
both of these vulnerabilities involved
issues with object property
authorization so they are combined under
the new title of broken object property
level authorization
as it states attack Vector description
apis tend to expose endpoints that
return all objects properties this is
particularly valid for rest apis for
other protocols such as graphql it may
require crafted requests to specify
which properties should be returned
identifying these additional properties
that can be manipulated requires more
effort but there are a few automated
tools available to assist in this task
the oauth security weakness description
States inspecting API responses is
enough to identify sensitive information
in returned object's representation
fuzzing is usually used to identify
additional hidden properties whether
they can be changed is a matter of
crafting an API request and analyzing
the response side effect analysis may be
required if the target property is not
returned in the API response the oasp
impacts description States unauthorized
access to private or sensitive object
properties may result in data disclosure
data loss or data corruption under
certain circumstances unauthorized
access to object properties can lead to
privileged escalation or partial to full
account takeover
as previously stated broken object
property level authorization or bopla is
a combination of mass assignment and
excessive data exposure in the 2023
release notes the security project
states that these two vulnerabilities
were combined focusing on the common
root cause object property level
authorization validation failures the
WASP API security project also States an
API endpoint is vulnerable if either the
API endpoint exposes properties of an
object that are considered sensitive and
should not be read by the user which is
the excessive data exposure or the API
endpoint allows a user to change add or
delete the value of a sensitive object's
property which the user should not be
able to access which is mass assignment
excessive data exposure is when an API
endpoint responds with more information
than is needed to fulfill a request this
often occurs in cases when the provider
expects the API consumer to filter
results when a consumer requests
specific information the provider might
respond with all sorts of information
assuming the consumer will then remove
any data they don't need from the
response when this vulnerability is
present it can be the equivalent of
asking someone for their name and having
them respond with their name date of
birth email address number and the
identification of every other person
they know
for example if an API consumer requests
information for their user account and
receives information about other user
accounts as well the API is exposing
excessive data check out the written
content for an example of an excessive
data exposure of vulnerability
excessive data exposure is in the API
vulnerability that is very difficult to
detect with automated scanners in
addition this vulnerability will often
bypass every Security Control in place
to protect sensitive information and
hand sensitive data to an attacker
simply because they use the API
to detect excessive data exposure API
providers must test API endpoints and
review the information sent in the
response Mass assignment occurs when an
API consumer includes more parameters in
its requests than the application
intended and the application adds these
parameters to code variables or internal
objects in this situation a consumer may
be able to edit object Properties or
escalate the Privileges for example an
application might have an account update
functionality that the user should use
only to update their username password
and address if the consumer can include
additional parameters in the request
related to their account such as the
account privilege level or sense of
information like an account balance and
the application accepts those parameters
without checking them against the
whitelist of permitted actions the
consumer could take advantage of this
weakness to change these values imagine
an API is called to create an account
with parameters for user and password
the user could be happy hacker password
could be great password123 while reading
the API documentation regarding the
account creation process an attacker
could discover that there's an
additional property which is admin that
the API provider uses to create
administrative accounts an attacker
could add this to a request and set the
value to true if the API does not
sanitize the request input it is
vulnerable to mass assignment an
attacker could use the request to create
their own admin account on the back end
the vulnerable web app will add the key
value attribute is admin equal true to
the user object and make the user the
equivalent of an administrator for that
application the OS preventative measures
State when exposing an object using an
API endpoint always make sure that the
user should have access to the object
properties you expose avoid using
generic methods such as 2json and two
string instead cherry pick specific
object properties you specifically want
to return if possible avoid using
functions that automatically bind the
client's input into code variables
internal objects or object properties
allow changes only to the object's
properties that should be updated by the
client
Implement a schema-based response
validation mechanism as an extra layer
of security
as part of this mechanism Define and
enforce data returned by all API methods
keep return data structures to the bare
minimum according to the business
functional requirements for the endpoint
check out the written course content for
additional resources about bopla
API 4 2023 unrestricted resource
consumption is an API issue where the
provider of the API does not have
safeguards in place to prevent excessive
use of their API when there are no
restrictions for resource consumption
the API provider could become a victim
of a denial of service attack or
experience unnecessary Financial costs
unrestricted resource consumption is an
updated version of API 4 2019 lack of
resources and rate limiting
the oasp attack Vector description
States exploitation requires simple API
requests multiple concurrent requests
can be performed from a single local
computer or by cloud computing resources
most of the automated tools available
are designed to cause denial of service
via High loads of traffic impacting API
service rate
the OS security weakness description
States it's common to find apis that do
not limit client interactions or
resource consumption crafted API
requests such as those including
parameters that control the number of
resources to be returned and Performing
response status time length analysis
should allow identification of the issue
the same is valid for batched operation
although threat agents don't have
visibility over costs impact this can be
inferred based on the service provider's
business
the oasp impacts description States
exploitation can lead to denial service
due to Resource starvation but it can
also lead to operational cost increase
such as those related due to that
infrastructure due to higher CPU demand
increasing cloud storage needs Etc the
oasp API security project States an API
is vulnerable if at least one of the
following limits is missing or set
inappropriately either too low or too
high
execution timeouts maximum allocable
memory maximum number of file
descriptors maximum number of processes
maximum upload file size number of
operations to perform in a single API
client request with things like graphql
batching number of Records per page to
return in a single request response and
third-party service provider spending
limit
every API request has a technical and
financial cost when API providers do not
enforce limitations on resource
consumption there's an increased risk of
denial of service distributed denial of
service unnecessary Financial costs and
degradation of the quality of service to
other users in addition rate limiting
plays an important role in the
monetization and availability of apis
many API providers monetize their apis
by limiting requests and allowing paid
customers to request more information
rapid API for example allows some API
providers to also have infrastructure
that automatically scales with the
number of API requests in these cases an
unlimited number of requests would lead
to a significant and easily preventable
increase in infrastructure costs
the OS preventative measures States
Docker makes it easy to limit memory CPU
number of restarts file descriptors and
processes Implement a limit on how often
a client can call the API within a
defined time frame notify the client
when the limit is exceeded by providing
the limit number and the time at which
the limit will be reset add proper
server-side validation for query string
and request body parameters specifically
the one that controls the number of
Records to be returned in the response
Define an enforce maximum size of data
on all incoming parameters and payloads
such as maximum length for Strings and
maximum number of elements and arrays
check out the written course content for
additional resources about unrestricted
resource consumption
API 5 2023 broken function level
authorization or baffla is a
vulnerability where API functions have
insufficient access controls
where Bola is about access to data
baffla is about altering or deleting
that data in addition a vulnerable API
would allow an attacker to perform
actions of other roles including
administrative actions to drive the
point home a fintech API susceptible to
Bola would allow an attacker the ability
to see what is in the bank account of
another user while the same API
vulnerable to baffle would allow an
attacker to transfer funds from other
users accounts to their own
oauth attack Vector description States
exploitation requires the attacker to
send legitimate API calls to an API
endpoint that they should not have
access to as an anonymous user or
regular non-privileged user exposed
endpoints will be easily exploited
the OS security weakness description
States authorization checks for a
function or resource are usually managed
via configuration or code level
implementing proper checks can be
confusing tasks since modern
applications can contain many types of
roles groups and complex user
hierarchies
it's easier to discover these flaws in
apis since apis are more structured and
accessing different functions is more
predictable
the oasp impacts description states such
flaws allow attackers to access
unauthorized functionality
administrative functions are key targets
for this type of attack and may lead to
data disclosure data loss or data
corruption ultimately it may lead to
service disruption
broken function level authorization or
baffla is a vulnerability where a user
of one privilege level can use the API
functionality of a different user user
group or another privileged level
API providers will often have different
privilege levels for different types of
accounts such as public users Merchants
Partners vendors administrators and so
on
baffler can be exploited for
unauthorized use of lateral functions or
a similarly privileged group or it could
be exploited for privileged escalation
where an attacker can use the functions
of a more privileged group
particularly interesting API functions
to access include those that deal with
sensitive information resources that
belong to another group and
administrative functionality like user
account management
if an API has different privilege levels
it may use different endpoints to
perform those privileged actions for
example a bank may use user ID slash
account slash balance as an endpoint for
a user wishing to access their account
information and then use slash admin
account slash user ID as an endpoint for
an administrator that needs to access
user account information if the
application does not have access
controls implemented correctly an
attacker will be able to perform
administrative actions and perform an
account takeover an API won't always use
administrative endpoints for
administrative functionality instead the
functionality could be based on
different HTTP request methods like get
post put and delete
if a provider doesn't restrict the HTTP
methods or verbs an attacker can use
simply making it an unauthorized request
with a different method could indicate a
bathroom vulnerability
when testing for bathla look for any
functionality that an attacker could use
to their advantage these functions
include but are not limited to altering
user accounts deleting user resources
and gaining access to restricted
endpoints
for example if an API gave Partners the
ability to add new users to the partner
group but did not restrict this
functionality to the specific group any
user could add themselves to any group
moreover if an attacker added themselves
to a group there's a good chance that
they'll be able to access that group's
sensitive resources take a look at the
written course content for an example of
a baffled attack
the OS preventative measures State your
application should have a consistent and
easy to analyze authorization module
that is invoked from all your business
functions frequently such protection is
provided by one or more components
external to the application code the
enforcement mechanisms should deny all
access by default requiring explicit
grants to specific roles for access to
every function review your API endpoints
against function level authorization
flaws while keeping in mind the business
logic of the application in groups
hierarchy make sure that all of your
administrative controllers inherit from
an administrative abstract controller
that implements authorization checks
based on the user's group or role make
sure that administrative functions
inside a regular controller Implement
authorization checks based on the user's
group and role check out the written
course content for additional resources
about broken function level
authorization
API 6 2023 unrestricted access to
sensitive business flows represents the
risk of an attacker being able to
identify and exploit API driven
workflows if vulnerable an attacker will
be able to leverage an organization's
API request structure to obstruct other
users this obstruction could come in the
form of spamming other users depleting
the stock of Highly sought after items
or preventing other users from using
expected application functionality
this is a new addition to the 2023 top
10 list
the oasp attack Vector description
States exploitation usually involves
understanding the business model backed
by the API finding sensitive business
flows and automating access to these
flows causing harm to the business the
OS security weakness description states
lack of a holistic view of the API in
order to fully support business
requirements tends to contribute to the
prevalence of this issue attackers
manually identify what resources or
endpoints are involved in the Target
workflow and how they work together if
if mitigation mechanisms are already in
place attackers need to find a way to
bypass them the oasp impacts description
States in general technical impact is
not expected exploitation might hurt the
business in different ways for example
prevalent legitimate users from
purchasing a product or lead to an
inflation in in the internal economy of
a game
regarding apis a flow is a series of
requests and responses that lead to an
operation if for example a purchase flow
for a web application does not restrict
access to a purchase process then a
scalper could automate requests to
instantly drain the stock of an item
down to nothing this is where mechanisms
like a completely automated public
touring test to tell computers and
humans apart
more better known as captcha comes into
play
if a flow has a capture mechanism that
requires human interaction then the
automated requests could be interrupted
and slow down automated purchasing check
out the written course material for an
example API flow used to help build a
notification bot for the PS5
customers and or scalpers competing to
purchase the PS5 would use API flows to
either complete purchases as soon as new
stock was available or alert upon stock
updates in the example an API flow is
used to automatically check for stock
updates and send out email alerts the
oauth preventative measures State the
mitigation planning should be done in
two layers business and Engineering
business should identify the business
flows that might harm the business if
they're excessively used engineering
should choose the right protection
mechanism to mitigate the business risk
some of the protection mechanisms are
more simple While others are more
difficult to implement the following
methods are used to slow down automated
threats device fingerprinting denies
service to unexpected client devices
tends to make threat actors use more
sophisticated Solutions thus more costly
for them next up is human detection
using either captcha or more advanced
biometric Solutions
non-human patterns analyze the user flow
to detect non-human patterns
for example the user accessed the add to
cart and complete purchase functions in
less than one second
consider blocking IP addresses of tour
exit nodes and well-known proxies secure
and limit access to apis that are
consumed directly by machines they tend
to be an easy target for attackers
because they often don't Implement all
the required protection mechanisms check
out the written course content for
additional resources about unrestricted
access to sensitive business flows
API 7 2023 server-side request forgery
is a vulnerability that takes place when
a user is able to control the remote
resources retrieved by an application an
attacker can use an API to supply their
own input in the form of a URL to
control the remote resources that are
retrieved by the targeted server an
attacker could Supply URLs that expose
private data scan the target's internal
Network or compromise the target through
remote code execution ssrf is also
number 10 on the 2021 OS top 10 list and
is a growing threat to apis
the oasp attack Vector description
States exploitation requires the
attacker to find an API endpoint that
accesses a URI that that's provided by
the client in general basic ssrf when
the response is returned by the attacker
is easier to exploit than blind ssrf in
which the attacker has no feedback on
whether or not the attack was successful
the OS security weakness description
States modern Concepts in application
development encourages developers to
access Uris provided by the client lack
of improper validation of such Uris are
common issues regular API requests and
response analysis will be required to
detect the issue when the response is
not returned detecting the vulnerability
requires more effort and creativity
the OAS impacts description States
successful exploitation might lead to
internal Services enumeration
information disclosure bypassing
firewalls or other security mechanisms
in some cases it can lead to denial of
service or the server being used as a
proxy to hide malicious activities ssrf
is a vulnerability that takes place when
an application retrieves remote
resources without validating user input
when an attacker has control over the
resources of server requests then they
can gain access to sensitive data are
worse completely compromise a vulnerable
host the impact of this vulnerability is
that an attacker would be able to
leverage the target server to perform
and process requests that they Supply
note that bug battery payouts for ssrf
are driven based on the impact can be
demonstrated with a proof of concept the
higher the demonstrated impact the
higher the Bounty there are two general
types of ssrf that are worth noting
in-band ssrf and out of band ssrf also
known as blind ssrf in in-band ssrf
means that the server responds with the
resources specified by the end user if
the attacker specifies a payload such as
google.com to a server with an in-band
necessary vulnerability the server would
make the request to google.com and then
respond to the attacker with information
served from google.com
line ssrf takes place when the attacker
supplies a URL and the server makes the
request but the server does not send the
information back from that specified URL
to the attacker in the case of blind
ssrf an attacker would need control over
a web server that would capture the
request from the target as proof that
they were able to force the server to
make this request
in the course inband ssrf example an
attacker makes a request that includes a
URL that will be used to update the
stock of an item in the store the
attacker is able to replace that item
stock URL with a local host URL to a
directory with a password the server is
vulnerable and provides the password
back to the attacker
blind ssrf takes place when a vulnerable
server performs a request from user
input but does not send back the
response to the attacker indicating a
successful attack in other words the
victim server makes the request to the
URL specified by the attacker but the
attacker does not receive a direct
message back from the victim server in
this case to know if the request was
made an attacker will need to have some
control over the web server that is
specified in the attack
for examples and demonstrations of
in-band and out-of-band ssrf attacks
check out the written course material
the OS preventative measures States
isolate the resource fetching mechanism
in your network usually these features
are aim to retrieve remote resources and
internal ones whenever possible use
allow allow lists of remote Origins
users are expected to download resources
from such as Google drive or gravatar
URL schemes and ports accepted media
types for a given functionality
disable HTTP redirections use a
well-tested and maintained URL parser to
avoid issues caused by URL parsing
inconsistencies validate and sanitize
all client supplied input data do not
send raw responses to clients
check out the written course content for
additional resources about SSRI
API 8 2023 security misconfiguration
represents a catch-all for many
vulnerabilities related to the systems
that host apis when an api's security is
misconfigured it can be detrimental to
the confidentiality integrity and
availability of the API provider's data
due to the wide variety of flaws that
could exist the impacts of an exploited
security misconfiguration can range from
information disclosure to data breach
the oasp attack Vector description
States attackers will often attempt to
find unpatched flaws common endpoints or
unprotected files and directories to
gain unauthorized access or knowledge of
the system
the OS security we've missed description
States security misconfiguration can
happen at any level of the API stack
from the network level to the
application Level automated tools are
available to detect and exploit
misconfigurations such as unnecessary
services or Legacy options
the oaspa impacts description States
security misconfigurations can not only
expose sensitive user data but also
system details that can lead to full
server compromise security
misconfigurations include all the
mistakes that API providers can make
within the supporting systems of an API
security misconfigurations are really a
set of weaknesses that include
misconfigured headers misconfigured
Transit encryption the use of default
accounts the acceptance of unnecessary
HTTP methods a lack of input
sanitization and verbose error messaging
for example if the API supporting
security configuration reveals an
unpatched vulnerability there's a chance
that an attacker could leverage a
published exploit to easily own the API
and its systems a lack of input
sanitization could allow attackers to
upload malicious payloads to the server
apis often play a key role in automating
processes so imagine being able to
upload payloads that the server
automatically processes into a format
that could be remotely executed or
executed by an unsuspecting end user
for example if an upload endpoint was
used to pass uploaded files to a web
directory then it could allow the upload
of a script navigating to the URL where
the file is located could launch the
script resulting in direct shell access
to the web server additionally a lack of
input sanitization can lead to
unexpected behavior on the part of the
application API providers use headers to
provide the consumer with instructions
for handling the response and security
requirements misconfigured headers can
result in sensitive information
disclosure downgrade attacks and
cross-site scripting attacks many API
providers will use additional Services
alongside their API to enhance API
related metrics or to improve security
it's fairly common that those additional
services will add headers to requests
for metrics and perhaps at some level of
assurance to the consumer the X powered
by header reveals back-end technology
headers like this one often advertise
the exact supporting service and its
version an attacker could use
information like this to search for
exploitsub publish for that version of
software the cross-site scripting
protection header is exactly what it
sounds like a header that's meant to
prevent cross-site scripting attacks
cross-site scripting is a common type of
injection vulnerability where an
attacker could insert scripts into a web
page and trick end users into clicking
on malicious links acrossite scripting
protection header with a value of 0
indicates no protections in place and a
value of 1 indicates that the objection
is turned on this header and others like
it clearly reveals whether or not a
security control is in place
the X response time header is middleware
that provides the usage metrics in this
example in the written course material
its value represents 566 milliseconds
but if the API isn't configured properly
this header can function as a side
Channel used to reveal existing
resources if the X response time header
has a consistent response time for
non-existing records for example but
increases its response time for certain
other records that actually exist this
could be an indication to an attacker
that they've come across these files
say for instance an attacker can
determine that a bogus account like
slash user slash account slash this
definitely does not exist has an average
response time of 25 milliseconds the
attacker can know that their existing
account is user slash account slash 1021
which receives an X response time of 510
milliseconds an attacker could then send
requests brute forcing account numbers
and review the results and see which
account numbers resulted in drastically
increased response times
any API providing sensitive information
to Consumers should use transport layer
security to encrypt the data even if the
API is only provided internally
privately or at a partner level
transport layer security the protocol
that encrypts https traffic is one of
the most basic ways to ensure that API
requests and responses are protected
when being passed across a network
misconfigured or missing Transit
encryption can cause API users to pass
sensitive API information and clear text
across networks in which case an
attacker could capture the responses and
requests with a man in the middle attack
and read them plainly they would simply
have to intercept the network traffic
with a network protocol analyzer like
Wireshark to see the information being
communicated between a consumer and a
provider when a service uses default
accounts or credentials and the defaults
are known an attacker can use those
credentials to assume the role of that
account this could allow them to gain
access to sensitive information or
administrative functionality and
potentially lead to a compromise of the
supporting systems lastly if an API
provider allows unnecessary HTTP methods
there's an increased risk that the
application won't handle these methods
properly or will result in sensitive
information disclosure out of all the
vulnerabilities covered on the oauth's
top 10 apia 2023 security
misconfiguration is one of the only ones
that can be detected by web application
vulnerability scanners automated
scanners like verb Suite nessus qualis
OS zap and mcdo will automatically check
responses from the web server to
determine the version information
headers cookies Transit encryption
configuration and parameters to see if
expected security measures are missing
security misconfigurations can also be
checked manually if you know what you're
looking for by inspecting the headers
SSL certificate cookies and parameters
the OS preventative measure states that
API life cycle should include a
repeatable hardening process leading to
a fast and easy deployment of a properly
locked out environment a task to review
and update configurations across the
entire API stack the review should
include orchestration files API
components and cloud services an
automated process to continuously assess
the effectiveness of the configuration
and settings in all environments
furthermore ensure that all API
Communications from the client to the
API server and any Downstream Upstream
components happen over encrypted
Communication channel regardless of
whether it is an internal or
public-facing API be specific about
which HTTP verbs each API can be
accessed by all other HTTP verbs should
be disabled API is expecting to be
accessed from browser-based clients
should at least Implement a proper
cross-origin resource sharing policy
include applicable security headers
restrict incoming content types data
formats to those that meet the business
functional requirements ensure all
servers in the HTTP server chain process
incoming requests in a uniform manner to
avoid desync issues where applicable
Define and enforce all API response
payload schemas including error
responses to prevent exception traces
and other valuable information from
being sent back to an attacker
check out the written course content for
additional resources about API security
misconfigurations
API 9 2023 improper Inventory management
represents the risks involved with
exposing non-production and unsupported
API versions when this is present the
non-productive and unsupported versions
of the API are often not protected by
the same security rigor as the
production versions this makes improper
Inventory management a gateway to other
API security vulnerabilities
the OS attack Vector description States
threat agents usually get unauthorized
access through old API versions or
endpoints left running unpatched and
using secret a weaker security
requirements alternatively they may get
access to sensitive data through a third
party with whom there is no reason to
share data with
the OAS security weakness description
States outdated documentation makes it
more difficult to find and or text
vulnerabilities lack of assets inventory
and retirement strategies leads to
running unpatched systems resulting in
leakage of sensitive data it's common to
find unnecessarily exposed API hosts
because of modern Concepts like
microservices which makes applications
easy to deploy and independent simple
Google Dorking DNS enumeration or using
specialized search engines for various
types of servers connected to the
internet will be enough to discover
targets the oasp impacts description
States attackers can gain access to
sensitive data or even take over the
server sometimes different API version
deployments are connected to the same
database with real data threat agents
May exploit deprecated endpoints
available to in Old API versions to get
access to administrative functions or
exploit known vulnerabilities improper
Inventory management takes place when an
organization exposes apis that are
unsupported or still in developed as
with any software old API versions are
more likely to contain vulnerabilities
because they are no longer being patched
and upgraded likewise apis that are
still being developed and are typically
not as secure as their production API
counterparts improper Inventory
management can lead to other
vulnerabilities such as excessive data
exposure information disclosure Mass
assignment improper rate limiting and
API injection for attackers this means
that discovering an improper inventory
management vulnerability is only the
first step towards further exploitation
of an API detecting improper Inventory
management can be tested by using
outdated API documentation changelogs
and version history on repositories for
example if an organization's API
documentation has not been updated along
with the api's endpoints it could
contain references to portions of the
API that are no longer supported
organizations often include versioning
information in their endpoints names to
distinguish between older and newer
versions such as V1 V2 or V3 and so on
API still in development often use paths
such as slash alpha beta test uat and
demo if you know that an API is now
using API
v3.org admin but a part of the API
documentation refers to API v1.org admin
you could try testing different
endpoints to see if API V1 or V2 are
still active additionally the
organization's change log May disclose
the reasons why B1 was updated or
retired if an attacker has access to V1
they can test those for weaknesses
outside of using documentation an
attacker could discover improper
inventory vulnerabilities through the
use of guessing fuzzing or brute forcing
requests testing for improper assets
management is all about discovering
unsupported and non-production versions
of an API API providers will often
update services and the newer version of
the API in a variety of ways such as
api.target.com V3 or API V2 accounts or
API B3 accounts API versioning could
also be maintained as a header so you
could see something like accept version
equals 2.0 or accept API version equals
three in addition versioning could also
be set within a query parameter or the
request body so you could see Slash API
accounts version equals 2 or post to API
accounts with a versioning equals 1.8
non-production versions of an API
include any version of the AP API that
was not meant for end user consumption
non-production versions could include
api.uat.target.com
beta.api.com API private API partner or
API test in these instances earlier
versions of the API May no longer be
patched or updated
since the older versions lack this
support they may expose the API to
additional vulnerabilities and Lead an
attacker to a path that can be used to
compromise the provider's data the OS
preventative measures States inventory
all API hosts and document important
aspects of each one of them focusing on
the API environment such as production
staging tests or development who should
have network access to the house such as
public internal or Partners in the API
version inventory integrated services
and document important aspects such as
their role in the system what data is
exchanged and its sensitivity
document all aspects of your apis such
as authentication errors redirects rate
limiting cross-origin resource sharing
course policy and endpoints including
their parameters requests and responses
generate documentation automatically by
adopting Open Standards include the
documentation build in your CI CD
pipeline make API documentation
available to those authorized to use the
API use external protection measures
such as an API security firewall for all
exposed versions of your apis not just
for the current production versions
avoid using production data with
non-production API deployments if this
is unavoidable these endpoints should
get the same security treatment as the
production ones when newer versions of
the API include security improvements
perform risks analysis risk analysis to
make the decision of the mitigation
action required for the older version
for example whether it is possible to
backport the improvements without
breaking API compatibility or you need
to take the older version but quickly
enforce all clients to move to the
latest version
for additional resources about improper
Inventory management check out the
written course materials
API 10 2023 unsafe consumption of apis
is the only item on the top 10 list that
focuses Less on the risks of being an
API provider and more on the risks of
being an API consumer
unsafe consumption is really a trust
issue when an application is consuming
the data of a third-party API it should
treat those with a similar trust to user
input by that I mean there should be
little to no trust so data consumer from
third-party apis should be treated with
similar security standards as end user
supplied input if a third-party API
provider is compromised then that
insecure API connection back to the
consumer becomes a new attack Vector for
the attacker to leverage in the case of
an insecure API connection that could
mean the complete compromise of
organizations in securely consuming data
from that API provider
the OS attack Vector description States
exploiting this issue requires attackers
to identify and potentially compromise
other apis or Services the target apis
integrated with usually this information
is not publicly available or the
integrated API or service is not easily
exploitable
the OS security weakness description
States developers tend to trust and not
verify the endpoints that interact with
external or third-party apis relying on
weaker security requirements such as
those regarding Transport Security
authentication authorization and input
validation sanitization
attackers need to identify Services the
target API interacts with or integrates
with and eventually compromise them the
oasp impacts description States the
impact varies according to what the
target API does with pulled data
successful exploitation may lead to
sensitive information exposure to
unauthorized actors many kinds of
injections or denial of service
most of the 2023 API security top 10 is
about apis and the API provider an API
can often serve as the path of least
resistance for an attacker so if an
attacker compromises a third-party API
provider then that third party's
connection to other businesses can
become an additional attack Vector if
that API is over an unencrypted
connection that an attacker would be
able to capture sensitive data and clear
text if that third-party API isn't held
to similar security standards as
internet-facing apis then it could also
be vulnerable to injection authorization
authentication and other compromising
attacks the OS preventative measure
States when evaluating service providers
assess their API security posture ensure
all API interactions happen over a
secure Communication channel
always validate and properly sanitize
data received from integrated apis
before using it maintain an allow list
of well-known locations integrated apis
made redirect yours to do not blindly
follow redirects for additional
resources about unsafe consumption of
apis check out the written course
materials
injection vulnerabilities have plagued
web applications for over two decades
they take place when an attacker can
send commands that are executed by the
systems that support the web application
the most common forms of injection
attacks are SQL injection cross-eyed
scripting and operating system command
injection apis are yet another attack
Vector for these critical attacks to be
communicated from an attacker to the
supporting system supporting databases
and systems
the oasp 2019 attack Vector description
States attackers will feed the API with
malicious data through whatever
injection vectors are available such as
Direct in parameters integrated Services
expecting it to be sent to an
interpreter the OS 2019 security
weakness description States injection
flaws are very common and are often
found in SQL ldap or nosql queries OS
commands XML parsers and orm these flaws
are easy to discover when reviewing the
source code attackers can use scanners
and fuzzers to find these
the OS 2019 impacts description States
injection can lead to information
disclosure and data loss it may also
lead to denial of service or complete
host takeover
injection flaws exist when a request is
passed to the API supporting
infrastructure and the API provider
doesn't filter the input to remove
unwanted characters as a result the
infrastructure might treat the data from
the request as code and run it when this
sort of flaw is present an attacker will
be able to conduct injection attacks
like SQL injection nosql injection and
system command injection when these
injection attacks are successful the API
delivers an unsanitized payload directly
to the operating system running the
application or a query to its database
as a result if an attacker sends a
payload containing SQL commands to a
vulnerable API that uses a SQL database
the API will pass the commands to the
database which will process and perform
the commands the same will happen with
vulnerable nosql databases and affected
systems
verbose error messaging HTTP response
codes and unexpected API Behavior can
all be Clues to an attacker and will be
an indication that they have discovered
an injection flaw say for example an
attacker were to send or one equals zero
zero-jas as an address in an account
registration process the API may pass
that payload directly back to the
backend SQL database where the or one
equals zero statement which would fail
as one does not equal zero causing a SQL
error an error in the backend database
could show up as a response to the
consumer in this case the attacker who's
the consumer might receive a response
like error equals you have an error in
your SQL syntax but any response
directly from the database or the
supporting system will serve as a clear
indicator that there's likely an
injection vulnerability
injection vulnerabilities are often
complemented by other weaknesses like
poor input sanitization injection flaws
can have serious impacts by providing an
attacker with the ability to manipulate
an API supporting system or database
finding injection Clause requires
diligently testing API endpoints and
paying attention to how the API responds
then crafting requests that attempt to
manipulate the backend systems injection
attacks have been around for decades so
there are many Standard Security
controls that can be used to protect API
providers from them the OAS 2019
preventative measure States preventing
injection requires keeping data separate
from commands and queries perform data
validation using a single trustworthy
and actively maintained Library validate
filter and sanitize all client provided
data or other data coming from
Integrated Systems
special characters should be escaped
using the specific Syntax for the Target
interpreter prefer a safe API that
provides parameterized interface
always limit the number of returned
records to prevent Mass disclosure in
case of injection
validate incoming data using sufficient
filters to only allow valid values for
each input parameter
Define data types and strict patterns
for all string parameters
for additional resources about API
injection check out the written course
content
walking and monitoring are a necessary
and important layer of API Security in
order to detect an attack against an API
an organization must have monitoring in
place without sufficient logging and
monitoring an API providers operating in
the dark and API attacks are guaranteed
to go unnoticed until it's far too late
the OS 2019 attack Vector description
States attackers take advantage of a
lack of logging and monitoring to abuse
systems without being noticed the oauth
2019 security weakness description
states without logging and monitoring or
insufficient logging and monitoring it
is almost impossible to track suspicious
activities and respond to them in a
timely fashion
the OS 2019 impacts description states
without visibility over ongoing
malicious activities attackers have
plenty of time to fully compromise
systems
logs can reveal patterns in API usage
and can be used as evidence to
understand how an API is abused logging
and monitoring provide an audit trail of
activities and are often required for
compliance purposes an important part of
logging is to ensure that the logs have
integrity and cannot be altered by an
attacker monitoring an API will help
providers detect suspicious activities
and anomalous user Behavior this helps
providers be able to take action to
thwart attacks logging and monitoring
are essential for improving API
performance and security the OAS 2019
preventative measures States log all
failed authentication attempts denied
access and input validation errors log
should be written using a format suited
to be consumed by a log management
solution and should include enough
detail to identify the malicious actor
logs should be handled as sensitive data
and their integrity should be guaranteed
at rest and Transit configure a
monitoring system to continuously
monitor the infrastructure Network and
API functioning use a seam system to
Aggregate and manage logs from all
components of the API stack and hosts
configure custom dashboards and alerts
enabling suspicious activities to be
detected and responded to earlier
for additional resources about
insufficient logging and monitoring
check out the written course content
business logic vulnerabilities are
weaknesses within applications that are
unique to the policies and features of a
given API provider the exploitation of
business logic takes place when an
attacker leverages misplaced trust or
features of an application against the
API identifying business logic
vulnerabilities can be challenging due
to the unique nature of each business
the impact of these vulnerabilities can
arrange based on the severity of the
vulnerable policy or feature
my attack Vector description for this
business logic vulnerabilities are
unique to each application and exploit
the normal intended functioning of an
application's business processes they
often require specific knowledge of the
application functionality and the flow
of transactions or data since these
vulnerabilities are specific to the
business logic of each application
there's no one-size-fits-all approach to
identifying them
my security weakness description States
business logic vulnerabilities arise
when the assumptions and constraints of
a given business process aren't properly
enforced in the application's control
structures this allows users to
manipulate the application's
functionality to achieve outcomes that
are detrimental to the business
these weaknesses typically occur when
developers fail to anticipate the
various ways that an application's
features can be misused or when they
don't consider the wider context of the
business rules
this is often due to a lack of
comprehensive understanding of the
application business logic a lack of
input validation or incomplete function
level authorization checks
my impact's description States business
logic vulnerabilities can cause a
variety of technical impacts depending
on the specific flaw in the systems
involved these impacts can range from
unauthorized access to data or
functionality to a total bypass of
system controls business logic
vulnerabilities also known as business
logic flaws or blfs are intended
features of an application that
attackers can use maliciously for
example if an API has an upload feature
that instructs users to only upload
certain coded payloads but doesn't
actually validate those encoded payloads
a user could upload any file as long as
it was encoded this would allow end
users to upload and potentially execute
arbitrary code including malicious
payloads vulnerabilities of this sort
normally come about from an assumption
that API consumers will follow
directions be trustworthy or only use
the API in a certain way in those cases
the organization essentially depends on
trust as a security control by expecting
the consumer to act benevolently
unfortunately even good-natured API
consumers make mistakes that could lead
to a compromise of the application the
Experian partner API leak in 2021 was a
great example of an API trust failure a
certain Experian partner was authorized
to use experience API to perform credit
checks but the partner added the api's
credit check functionality to their web
application and inadvertently exposed
all partner level requests to users this
request could be intercepted when using
the partner's web application and if it
included a name and address the Experian
API would respond with the individual's
credit score and credit risk factors
one of the leading causes of this
business logic vulnerability was that
the Experian trusted the partner to not
expose the API
another problem with trust is that
credentials like API Keys tokens and
passwords are constantly being stolen
and leaked when a trusted consumer's
credentials are stolen the consumer can
become a wolf in sheep's clothing and
wreak havoc without strong technical
controls in place business logic
vulnerabilities can often have the most
significant impact leading to
exploitation and compromise an api's
documentation can be a Telltale sign of
a business logic vulnerability
statements like the following should be
indications of potential business logic
flaws only use feature X to perform
function y do not do x with endpoint y
only admin should perform request X
these statements May indicate that the
API provider is trusting that end users
won't do any of the discourse
discouraged actions as instructed an
attacker will easily disobey such
request to test for the presence of
technical security controls another
business logic vulnerability comes about
when developers assume that consumers
will exclusively exclusively use a
browser to interact with the web
application and won't capture API
requests that take place behind the
scenes all it takes to exploit this sort
of weakness is for an attacker to
intercept requests and alter the API
request before it is sent to the
provider this would allow the attacker
to capture shared apics or use
parameters that could negatively impact
the security of the application
as an example consider a web app
authentication portal that a user
normally would employ to authenticate to
their account
say the web application issued an API
authentication request that included the
username and password along with a query
parameter multi-factor equals true
there's a chance that an attacker could
bypass multi-factor authentication by
simply altering the parameter to false
testing for business logic flaws can be
challenging because each business is
unique automated scanners will have a
difficult time detecting these issues as
the flaws are part of the api's intended
use you must understand how the business
and API operate and then consider how an
attacker could use these features to
their advantage one method of testing
for business logic flaws is to study the
application business logic with an
adversarial mindset and try breaking any
assumptions that have been made my
preventative measures for business logic
flaws include the following use a threat
modeling approach understand the
business processes and workflows your
API supports identify the potential
threats weaknesses and risks during the
design phase that can help to uncover
and mitigate business logic
vulnerabilities
reduce or remove trust relationships
with users systems or components
business logic vulnerabilities can be
used to exploit these trust
relationships leading to a broader
impact
regular training can help developers to
understand and avoid business logic
vulnerabilities training should cover
secure coding practices common
vulnerabilities and how to identify
potential issues during design encoding
phases
Implement a bug Bounty program
third-party penetration testing or
responsible disclosure policy this
allows security researchers who are a
step removed from the design and
delivery of an application to disclose
vulnerabodies they discover in apis
for additional resources about business
logic vulnerabilities check out the
written course material